how soon in the filmmaking process do
you start selling
the idea to your fan base and you have a
very enthused fan base some are local
some are not and
um
how soon did you start leaking news of
the frame basically the casting process
i guess with this we
you know we spent a long time trying to
decide what we were going to make next
and i was going between two different
scripts and the frame was one of them
and we ultimately decided to go with the
frame so once the script was done with
the frame we knew we were gonna move
forward on production then we
i guess started a frame facebook page
and the very first thing we put out was
just a picture of the front of the
script and that was a and that was
that was what six months before we
started it was almost exactly two years
ago yeah yeah so
um so yeah production was last summer uh
april to
late june 2013 and then it's been a year
of post-production we literally finished
the movie about two weeks ago
and um
we just waste no time we get we get
right onto the next thing but uh
yeah we put news out
i guess in november of 2012.
we just took a pic we started a frame
facebook page posted that picture on our
ink facebook page you know the frame by
jamin winans just a picture of the
script
um
and started to you know convert people
from our inc facebook page which you
know at least we have that as a starting
point um to start getting people
interested in this movie and then have
continued to kind of post stuff there
and post stuff on the frame page and
and i think that was it's a little bit
tricky because i think with
the way that we have put out the you
don't want to wear people out you know
and it's such a long journey from
um the script all the way through
post-production to premiering it you
have to be careful you don't completely
exhaust your fan base
um you know too much news and so i guess
we were we were fairly
sparse with the stuff that we're putting
out initially and then during the shoot
when we had a lot of interesting
pictures to to put up we shared those
with with the fans
and um
but it's just been
it's been very much i think it's been a
good process and that it's just kind of
kept people on board with the journey
the whole way through
and um so those those fans that we we
have now um feel a little bit more part
of the experience and they kind of are
more part of the experience i mean it's
kind of the uh
it's i mean it really does make a
difference for us when we're getting you
know fans you know just constantly
giving us just positive support all the
time and it really does make a
difference i mean i think um
a lot of people look at um i mean
there's there are downsides to social
networking as well but i mean generally
it's been a really positive thing
because it's really difficult to get
through it's just nice to be reminded
like oh wait no there are people that
like what we're doing like they support
us and um there is going to be an
audience for the film when it comes out
and that's
that's been a huge part of it so it's
just kind of helped us through through
the whole journey
how was your process when you
determined if something was too much
information or
if if it was the right time i mean i'll
see a lot of filmmakers they'll put out
oh exciting news is coming guys hang on
hang on and then another but but
sometimes i think it's almost better to
just wait hold it and then bam here it
is here's the exciting news what was
your process in deciding what you were
going to put out
we
we have a lot of discussions about that
because uh
we really only want to post stuff when
it's relevant we kind of went
largely off the grid after inc for a few
years and because we were fairly active
on twitter while we were promoting that
and
and there is a time where you just have
to live
as well and shut literally turn the
button off um
and so coming back and and starting to
kind of get the engines rolling for the
frame of get again is
it was a very conscious decision to
only post things when they're relevant
and we've actually gotten
i think you just get better at
not um
not letting the cat out of the bag too
early i'm just like okay well we're
gonna post our trailer on in two weeks
from now and so you know we'll do like a
three day lead up to that but we're not
going to start talking about it now
and we're not going to tell people
trailer in
you know three weeks or something it's
just
and also we've gotten
i think a lot more
it's hard to ride the line of
you know of course people love more
maybe personal information or something
like that but but we're a little more
i don't know private i guess
yeah we try to make sure that the the
content is more about
the films and less about us i guess
um
and because and i think that's a choice
i mean some people um really put their
own personalities out there and we tend
to think that our films are more
interesting than we are so
we try to keep it focused on the films
and um
so yeah and just trying to um only put
out like you said kind of stuff that we
think people are really going to be
interested and interested in and stuff
that feels more relevant but it's a
tricky thing because you know with this
film especially and and everything we do
we try to keep things very hush-hush so
kind of giving people something
without giving yeah without giving
anything away and yeah yeah
we put out a trailer that says nothing
about the movie right right but that's
exactly the trailer we wanted to make
we're really extreme on one side for
sure but um
but yeah but i think for the most part i
think it's been
you know fairly successful
and just on a side note in in keeping
things secretive it it makes people even
more curious i hope right yeah you hope
so i mean we've had discussions about
that too just uh
there was a reason why michael jackson
was the king of pop as he showed up
he danced his ass off and he was amazing
and then he just disappeared yeah and we
don't think we're michael jackson but
um
but uh
truly i mean i think that there's a um
because of all the availability of all
these social networks oh my god we've
got to be on instagram and twitter and
this and pinterest and all these things
and
there's a little bit of mystery lost you
know that mystique i think is gone a
little bit from a lot of people's
promotional efforts and i think the
movie
lends itself well to remaining
mysterious people after seeing it four
times are still mystified
i mean they're not but it's it
thematically works and it works for us
as people um but i think that's
something really cool like
you love a band or a rock star because
you're they're just there and then
they're gone you know
i hope anyway
but tonight you're screening in l.a
the q a will be here and will you stick
around afterward for
just sort of a meet and greet yeah okay
yeah absolutely we'll be around we're
also giving out free
11 by 17 posters so
you